se pueden tender estos procesos como una
persecución a quienes se oponen al
gobierno de miguel díaz canel
por supuesto que sí muchísimas gracias
por también por acá y repito por
supuesto que si se puede entender
exactamente de esa manera además vimos
en este artículo que saca un medio
oficial el primero acá en cuba un
marcado sesgo político donde intentan
justificar todo esto alegando que estas
personas eran delincuentes diciendo que
tenían antecedentes penales como por
ciento bastante harto de esas personas y
con esto quieren quitarle el carácter
político pero luego habla de que se
están juzgando por delitos de sedición
un delito que es eminentemente político
y las organizaciones han dicho que no
son 790 procesados sino que hay más de
1.000 detenidos finalmente cuál podría
ser la cifra y en qué condiciones está
estas personas
si las organizaciones de derechos
humanos han llevado un conteo por
ejemplo prisión es 'defender aula en su
último informe de 955 y las fiscalías
general de la república a través del
artículo de cubadebate habla de estos
790 personas nada más el tema es que
personas de diferentes justicia 11-j
cuales las organizaciones de derechos
humanos a que en cuba también el
observatorio cubano de derechos humanos
contabilizan además las personas que
fueron detenidas o sea que han sido
detenidas luego del 11 de julio
contabilizan además las personas que
fueron detenidas por el 15 de noviembre
que también hubo detenidas las personas
que han sido detenidas a lo largo del
año por manifestarse en contra el
sistema entre ellos por ejemplo luís
manuel otero alcántara y artista hoy en
huelga de hambre sexto día huelga de
hambre y sed del cual además la sociedad
civil cual está pidiendo en estos
momentos pe de vida hay también cuatro
personas más en huelga de hambre acá en
cuba de esprit y según las leyes cubanas
que puede pasar con los menores de edad
que están siendo procesados podrían ir a
la cárcel o no muy brevemente
y por supuesto pueden ir a la cárcel
porque además en las leyes cubanas
entienden a las personas que entienden
la mayoría de edad y que se pueden hacer
juicios con ellos después de los 16 años
por lo tanto aunque son menores de edad
no los entienden cómo está que pueden
procesar los perfectamente